غزل عبيد غزل احكي لي شو وضعكم ه انتم
ماساء وهي مش عيشه اصلا هي تمرنا وحنا
كثير كثير تناشد من الدول برا انهم
يدافعوا عن فلسطين لانه ها القط المسجد
الاقصى مش بس لنا لدول كلهم وبنتمنى انهم
يدافعوا عن فلسطين ويوقفوا معنا كيف
بتناموا كيف وضعكم بالليل بخيمه وامرات
لما تشتي كمان بتحمينا بتنزل علينا المطر
ملا وكمان انا هيني عيت من المطر لانه
الحفله اعطونا اياه ذوبه يوفي انهم ايش بس
يحمونا من البرد كيف وضع الميه الاكل
الشيه والله احنا ادوبه بنستخدمها لانه كل
اسبوع مره بيجي واحد عشان يعبي لنا و ولما
ندخل الحمامات بنقعد ساعتين بس لما نوقف
طابور عشان نروح على
الحمامات كيف هيك بكون الوضع لما انتم
توقفوا دور و والله بنتعب وكمان احنا
اجينا من غزه لهان ماشي على الاقدام كان
20 كيلو 20 20 كيلو مشينا هنا مشينا يعني
ماشي على
الاقدام كيف قدرتوا يعني انتم كان معكم
اطفال كنتوا عيله كيف جيتوا هنا القصف كان
الله كان معنا وكنا عادي يعني مش خافين
انا ما بخاف وكنا ماسكين كل واحد ماسك
ومهلك بس بنمشي عادي يعني المهم نكون
بامانه كل بخوف خايفين من المرحله الجايه
يعني خايفين تطول اه والله نن خايفين كثير
انا خواتي كثير بخافوا وبالليل كل ما يصير
دبه بص ماما صير يصوتوا بكون خايفين كثير
كثير واحنا خايفين من المرحله الجايه لاش
هي حتكون اصلا تكون ايش اكثر بزياده خوف
وتمرمط